the visual capitalist chart yeah you
want to pull that up yeah what did you
want to see on there yeah comments on it
yeah i just said
look i went down this chart and i was
looking at it right
and this is
this is a 94 trillion dollar world
economy today in one exactly and they're
basically saying by next year 2022 the
94 trillion we're going to
um add 6 trillion on top of it as a
world gdp economy
this is what i found encouraging so
usa still number one respect at almost
23 trillion dollars okay we printed more
money in the past 24 months than
literally
every other country than china makes in
a
full-on year every other country that's
how much money you're printed so other
than china here are the countries in the
top ten japan
5 trillion germany 4 trillion uk india
still under 3 trillion france italy
canada south korea you go other than
china everything in the top 10 is our
ally
something just to make note of number 11
russia 1.6 trillion we hear about big
bad russia big bad russia they have a
smaller economy than south korea just
put that in perspective they're the
largest country by land mass in the
world
and they make less they have less gdp
than south korea then you got brazil
australia spain mexico and not until you
get down into iran which makes us about
as much as saudi arabia at number 17 do
you have a you know quote unquote ally
of china
in the mix so
even if china does surpass united states
and i expect him to do so elon musk came
out and said that he probably thinks
it's going to be double in the next few
decades
the world
if we stay together you know nato allies
what have you
we still have
the i think
most
the top 10 allies other than china
two-thirds of the world gdp here's
here's what i then that's great that
you're saying that this is very good
news but i will tell you this
you have to keep in mind so what causes
china's gdp to get to 30 30 trillion
gdb gdp what'll cause it to get to 30
trillion how do you get to 30 trillion
how do you create that much commerce
still buying from china so that's that's
what i'm saying to you so no matter how
much those guys are all allies
you know how it's like it's like this
it's like everybody can come around and
talk about a guy until the guy
shows up in the room and what do they
say oh what's up johnny how are you
doing it's like oh geez
oh oh oh how are you oh my gosh so until
the guy walks in the room everybody
talks until he's eventually sitting
there saying dude we still need that
guy's manufacturing we it's kind of like
this fda okay
you know when they say this is fda
approved this is fda approved this is
fda approved what do you think they get
their funding
is it from china
what percentage of fda you think gets
their funding from uh from big pharma
what percentage do you think is big
pharma oh what far what percentage from
big big pharma yeah yeah 90 something
it's 45 so think about fda gets 45 their
funding from big pharma right so who do
you think fda reports to you think fda
reports to you
you think fda reports to me you think
fda wakes up every morning worried about
kids husbands wives or do you think fda
wakes up every morning saying we better
not lose that what
the 45
of
funding that we get from big pharma okay
how many large media companies are
controlled by big pharma so no matter
what when bernie sanders gets up and
says we shouldn't let big pharma do this
oh really go try to if every time he
says that cnn doesn't like that story
msnbc doesn't like that story why
because as much as cnn and msnbc will do
a soft story on big pharma they're not
going to go after big pharma the way
they go they go after trump why because
big pharma funds cnn right all of these
comp countries you just talked about
going up against china if china
makes their money because everybody
needs to rely on their medicine their ac
their technology their chips all this
stuff because of china
you're eventually going to get to a
point of desperation where you're going
to say china can we create an
arrangement together can we create a
contract together it is not a look every
great company
every great country every every great uh
league
that excels for a decade or two has a
great number one
a great number one inspires others okay
when america was number one what did
america inspire others to do maybe
capitalism works
okay
maybe capitalism works other countries
said we also ought to do capitalism but
if china
is number one
what are they inspiring other people to
do you think that's a good number one
for the world that's not good number one
so what i'm trying to say is
you know when you are number one you
have a lot of influence and power
uh i'm i'm very much pro here's a number
i follow do you know what is a
percentage of gdp that india has grown
this year in 2021
what do you think is the growth of gdp
percentage percentage eight and a half
eight and a half percent
point six percent higher than that last
year okay i love the fact that india is
growing right
well they're still
under three trillion dollars it's no
problem they're going to grow so look
how fast who was china 30 years ago
nobody right who's china today number
two who's india today
don't get it twisted look how quickly
india is going to so you're saying
that's going to be a good thing for the
fantastic if india is fantastic would it
be a good thing of the world if u.s i'm
sorry if india surpasses china and the
u.s bad number one india is not a bad
number is there a democracy india
doesn't wake up in the morning saying
you better think like us or else india
doesn't wake up in the morning with modi
saying take all the negative reviews off
india doesn't do that that's what china
does right china believes in force india
doesn't believe in force it's a very
it's a mindset you want the right
mindset to be number one why is steph
curry good for the nba because it gets
any other kid that's short saying i can
make it in the nba as well that's why
he's good for the nba okay do you
understand what i'm saying yeah of
course not everyone's going to be six
hours how many fifty like lebron you
could point six two one 180 by the way
250 was years ago he's more like 275 to
he runs like a center right now you're
looking to be like this guy's not a
three or two he's a five right now when
you look out speaking of pushing back
against china or a big pharma
you know it starts somewhere like bernie
like you brought up bernie bernie
sanders but
like as an example you know nba gets a
lot of heat for not pushing back against
china and what they did in hong kong and
you know pro-democracy and dara mori
houston rockets all that yeah but you
got to respect what like the women's
tennis association just did in china
are you kidding me what
remember when i i said this three months
ago on a podcast when it was me you
gerard and one other person and i said
watch the nba flip their position on
china when lebron tweets something bad
about china okay
you just saw the nba having to respond
to whose tweet that just came out in the
last week lebron's what did lebron say
what the hell is this covet floor code
tell me because it's really pissing me
off i want to play the game of
basketball right props to the guy the
guy that loves the game of basketball
he's not trying to stay out of the game
he ain't kyrie he's trying to play the
game right okay
no problem
lebron
is going to tweet something negative
about china in the next few months watch
when i matter of fact uh do me a favor
and notice
in your account so we know how to bring
back this video put it in your phone
notes and text it to me so i can
remember this date for us to remember
exactly when this happened lebron's
going to get out there he's going to say
something negative about china because
he's not going to have any choice not to
say it he has to say it he's going to
say it yeah everyone's going to flip
their position on china with nba why
would he do something like that
because
because enough of people have been
asking them the question to say why do
you call out trump why do you call out
this why do you call out that why do you
call out this yeah well you say nothing
about china why he's eventually going to
flip the switch and he's going to say
that but it's not going to happen for a
few months he'll eventually do that
anyway so you're thinking by the end of
this season
right because the season's going to be
on until june yeah and that's the next
three or six months i think it'll happen
he's going to come out and what do you
think it's going to be a tweet like
you're making a prediction right i'm
making a prediction he's going to do
something in 2022 saying something
negative about china
either defending an ally yeah of us
that's against china yeah or opposing
china this will happen next like
something like dara moris did when he uh
exited the protesters and exactly six to
twelve months that's going to happen so
you think he's ready for that chinese
backlash what do you think china will do
if lebron does something
no the way lebron is going to do it is
after knowing that the nba is not going
to go into china it's not going to
affect his pocket that's how it happens
he's going to become a billionaire in
the next regard to 24.
you actually think that he's that
concerned about his pocket let me ask
you a question for him to say something
about covett flew cold who's he calling
out
i think he's just calling out the double
standard that's out there just in
general do you think he's looking
calling out fouchy you think he's
calling out biden do you think he's
calling out the nba of course it is it's
a direct call out of the mba policies
and the nba policies are a direct
reflection of fouchy's policies and
fauci's policies are a direct reflection
of the guy that appointed him even after
trump which is who biden of course is a
call-out one million percent's a cola
yeah absolutely he took a risk when he
did that so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]